if you use the kind of standard
phraseology coming from environmental
economics they are basically two issues
they're poor market failure and policy
failure and biodiversity loss or loss of
ecosystems and associated biodiversity
resulting from that mark and failure of
course this is a classical thing it's a
theory of externalities why do
externalities persist because they're
elements of public goods including for
biodiversity elements of that's
importance not a pure public good but
some elements of biodiversity have
features of public goods and then you
have the classical approach to say at
least simpler environmental problems
economic instruments like Peruvian Texas
it's it's etc to internalize these
externalities why would you or why would
we as a state as a government introduced
some crude standards directly
prescribing individual instead of
introducing a smart environmental text
where everyone is optimizing at the
margin why would we do that wow there
might be for instance situations where
the regulators the guys who are going to
be regulated by the state they might be
relatively homogeneous right little
difference between producers that kind
of say pollute for instance so in that
case if they are pretty similar then
there will be no little gains from trade
anyways so why should we introduce a
sophisticated for instance tradable
permit scheme when a simple regulatory
standard would also do hmmm this is this
is one one of the aspects what they call
the economics of relatively simple tools
this particular applies when you have
many sources tiny perm on mobile
pollution sources wouldn't be really
practical to to have kind of tradable
permit schemes or something like that
for for your exhaust fumes coming from
your car so I had instead you simply go
ahead and
prescribed specific standards minimum
standards for cars sometimes of course
there is simply a need for quality cords
corner solutions here right those of you
who did environmental economics you you
know that typically we assume these nice
curvatures and then you have an inner
optimum right but if you talk about say
hazardous substances doesn't really make
sense all right we don't want to have
wouldn't make sense to tax plutonium
because we simply don't want it to be
around in the environment so in that
sense on that case regulation would
would do better and of course they are
kind of what I call technical issues
here and this is particularly
interesting from a biodiversity
perspective because biodiversity is such
a complex beast as I said it has aspects
of public goods to it has aspects of
private goods to it and it's typically
non-homogeneous so it's very difficult
to text biodiversity consumption or
landscape consumption it's possible to
attack so for dioxide emissions but for
biodiversity they have to come up with
something more like smarter so we don't
have a text base unlike for your
homogeneous pollutants and of course we
might in many cases again not
necessarily want to have an inner
optimum that's what I got what's called
non convexities right again going back
to the curvatures sometimes we need in a
sense extreme solutions one plot of land
where nothing happens where you have one
hundred percent conservation and another
plot of land with a fair distance in
between where a lot of things happened a
lot of economic activity with potential
negative impacts but the most
interesting solution is actually two
separate the two by way of spatial
planning and by establishment of
protected areas and this is all going
beyond
or beyond the traditional rearm of say
thinking about environmental economics
in terms of emissions taxation but for
biodiversity that that's a very
important aspect